[Applause]
Emma's got the ball trying to get loose
now bottle up and down grape liner for
the captain well hurts the screen and
Rose here those you cannot touch the
shooter and the shooter knows that is
what is right here little hesitation
right there freezes smart if it gets it
right back numbers for the Hornets come
Bob does it itself
he's got the last seven for the Hornet
the timber right there would
communication not communication with the
basketball Hornets for three at home
Celtics four and five on the road Kemba
in points 30 and 31 Hornets in desperate
need of a win and six sweeping Celtics
side of your group after a hole we're
showing it the captain ministry limit
off the ball that's the wrinkle this
year you try to take him off the ball
especially late Jimmy Butler really good
defensive player Marcus smart
ezal of clock right here Kemba Pops's
into a three
[Applause]
kappa patience the stream set by Cody
smart for some reason tries to go under
the screen that leads Al Horford on it